[Applause]
hi everyone I'm Greg from canva and
today I'm going to talk to you about
Argo kubernetes native workflows and
pipelines a brief agenda for my talk
today I'm going to give a bit of
background on canva and what we do there
I'm going to recap on what I mean when I
say workflow from a data engineering or
machine learning perspective then onto
the main topic of the talk where I
compare I'll go and air flow finally if
this time I'll do a very brief demo of
Argo in action and maybe a bit of QA if
the time runs over we can do this in the
the office hours that's been scheduled
after this talk so who or what is canva
canva is a Sydney based startup but
we're made up of awesome people from all
over the world we're on a mission to
empower the world to design we build an
app that allows you to create awesome
designs we have lots of templates and
images and videos so you can focus on
creating your flyer or your birthday
card or your t-shirt or your social
media graphic or even a presentation
like this one I created this
presentation in canva and I'm not even a
designer so I think it looks pretty good
I brought a bunch of swag with me from
Australia so if you want some stickers
or some freebies come chat to me in the
office hours so how does canva use
workflows we use workflows to improve
the search relevance in our media
library we also use workflows to
generate recommendations for our
templates to our users so sort of
classic search and recommendation
systems as some of the speakers earlier
today have spoken about these use cases
and others got us looking at the
workflow tools available on the market
and led us to auger and airflow but what
exactly is a workflow the Oxford English
Dictionary defines a workflow as the
sequence of industrial administrative or
other processes through which a piece of
work
passes from initiation to completion
clear as mud right I prefer the
Wikipedia description a workflow
consists of an orchestrated and
repeatable pattern of activity I really
like that word repeatable
I think repeatable processes like a but
it going to become more and more
important in the data engineering and
data science space but what we really
mean when we're talking about a workflow
in data engineering or machine learning
is a dag or directed acyclic graph a dag
consists of a number of steps or tasks
and each task is a discrete amount of
work these tasks have dependencies on
other tasks and certain tasks could run
in parallel while some tasks are
required to run in a predefined order
all these tasks together make up some
larger piece of work or a workflow some
examples you might have come across may
be an ETL or an ELT job a spark job
machine learning jobs CI jobs deployment
jobs the list goes on workflows clearly
cover a very broad range of use cases so
where do you start when picking a tool
there are so many different tools out
there Susie Luigi knife I Azkaban
arguably the most popular tool at the
moment is air flow can I see a show of
hands of how many people in the audience
are using air flow Oh quite a lot anyone
using Luigi no susie-wusie quite a lot
of boozy out of interest anyone using
AWS data pipeline are one oh cool I'll
talk to you so here's what an airflow
deck looks like you can see the
dependencies between the tasks and you
can see how they make up a larger piece
of work here's what a similar thing
looks like in AWS data pipeline AWS data
pipeline was the first tool that we were
using at canva I'll go I'll go a bit
more into that in the next section of my
talk and finally for comparison here's
what a dag looks
like in Argo you can see that all these
tools broadly have very similar and they
allow different pieces of work to be
broken up into discrete discrete tasks
and allow you to define the dependencies
between the tasks so how do we come to
compare Argo and airflow at kanva first
a story we were a very small team at
this point where there were about five
people who could be considered the data
team at canva we were using AWS data
pipeline and it worked it was actually
pretty good for us it was a complicated
tool but as a complicated problem and
it's solved it reliably for us but as
time went on cracks began to emerge as
they inevitably do the team grew in
scale and ambition and we started
running into limitations with AWS data
pipeline the frustrations and the
grumbling started to happen more and
more frequently some issues that we ran
into were there were limitations and
then types of the ec2 instances that you
could run in the AWS data pipeline
installing custom software is slow and
awkward we had to develop custom
workarounds for the scheduling system we
ended up building our own cron triggers
to activate the workflows it's also a
fairly niche tool there's not much of a
commute community or knowledge share
around it these issues and others got us
looking into alternative workflow tools
airflow was the obvious choice to
consider but we'd also come across
another project called Argo that ticked
a lot of boxes for us on paper we didn't
want to spend too much time evaluating
all the tools on the market so we
decided to conduct a comprehensive proof
of concept between Argo and airflow to
see which one would win for us I'm sure
everyone is already familiar with
airflow but I'll just give a brief intro
to airflow airflow is the project that
originated at air B&B and is now an
Apache project you write your operators
in your dag in Python that is a huge
community it's open source so you can
host it yourself or if you're interested
in commercial software as a service
offerings you can look at cloud composer
from Google or astronomer Argo is a
project that originated at Abbey
and into it through their acquisition of
a company called athletics
it is a kubernetes native tool written
in golang it is made up of a custom
resource definition in kubernetes and a
custom controller that manages these
custom resources with Argo the dag is
made up of containers so it can be
written in any language not only Python
can I get a show of hands from the
audience on how many people are using
kubernetes in their work oh wow cool so
for our proof of concept we decided to
implement a simple but realistic data
pipeline that we already had and we
decided to re-implement it an airflow in
our go to see what it would take to
migrate to this tool we set up both
airflow and Argo on AWS we decided to
set things up ourselves to get a better
understanding of the various components
and dependencies of both projects we
came up with a few evaluation criteria
and we got to work our main evaluation
criteria was simple it had to be
suitable for the existing kanva
workloads which are mostly apache spark
it had to be easy to set up and operate
it needed a good workflow deployment
story it needed to have live logging and
live view our updates we also need
timeouts and retries and reproducibility
is very important to us we want things
to be deterministic a few things that we
weren't looking for we weren't looking
for a visual UI for editing DAGs we are
all comfortable writing code in the team
and we prefer writing code to updating
workflows in a UI we aren't really
looking for extremely dynamic tags our
tags are mostly static so basic
conditional logic and loops are all that
we really need we don't have any use
cases at the moment where we don't have
a good idea of the inputs and outputs at
the start of a workflow and updating a
dag at runtime isn't
thing that we wanted we consider a
modification to add AG to be a change a
new version of the dag and we expect it
to be committed to get so what were the
results of our evaluation both airflow
and Argo are very capable tools we found
that both could support canva workloads
both offer live UI updates and logging
and both have timeouts and retries but
there must have been some issues right
the main issues we found with air flow
with immutability and deployment of Dax
the deployment of DAGs is clumsy and you
either have to pole git or use our sink
or some sort of shared file system to
share the DAGs between the scheduler and
executives there isn't an API to deploy
your DAGs this means that the dag that
is deployed is not necessarily the dag
that runs because the DAGs on the
scheduler and the DAGs
on the executives are sort of eventually
consistent we also found the deployment
of air flow itself to be fairly
complicated there are a lot of moving
parts and while not all unnecessary
depending on your scale you almost
certainly want to run the database and
the schedule on separate machines you
also have to monitor the web UI the
scheduler and the executives if you
scale out using the salary executor it
gets even more complex we also notice
that there was a lot of excitement
around the kubernetes executor for
airflow so we thought why not just use
Cooper Nettie's directly instead of
course no tool is a Silver Bullet and
there are issues with Argo as well one
issue with Argo is the immense amount of
yellow you have to deal with anybody
using kubernetes knows the management
and templating of all this llamó gets
very messy very quickly Argo also
requires Cuban Ares this is a high
amount of complexity in itself and isn't
for everyone it has a lot of benefits
but it is can be a chore to operate even
on some of them managed at kubernetes
systems from AWS Google or Microsoft so
what was our decision
ultimately both tools are very capable
and the main thing that let air flow
down for us was its deployments of dag
story
we chose Argo because it has a better
deployment story for the DAGs via an API
and command-line tool we found that the
DAGs were more declarative we also liked
how the tasks are defined as containers
so if we do need to move to another tool
in future as long as the tool can run
containers it should be a relatively
straightforward migration path I'm now
going to show a brief demo of augur in
action I wasn't brave enough to do a
live demo so we've got it recorded
oh not that one
okay so this is going to be a basic demo
showing what an agro dag looks like from
the user perspective so you can see in
my folder here I've got two llamo files
dag workflow and dag coin-flip I'm going
to run the dag workflow this is what the
dag typically looks like so at the top
you can see the custom kubernetes
resource definition of workflow it's of
kind workflow and you can see that I'm
going to generate a name called dag
workflow the entry point for my dag is
is start and you can see that I've
defined a template called stock start
there
that reference that is a dag and inside
the dag the bag is made up of tasks
remember so we start with task a and
task a has no dependencies so it's going
to be the task that will start running
immediately you can have multiple entry
points in our go so you don't only need
to have one interest task you can have
numerous you can see the task the task
is going to run echo which you'll see a
bit later and it's going to pass some
parameters message and the value a
you can see task B as well it has a list
of dependencies and it depends on a and
C likewise C depends on a as well and
finally task D it depends on B and C so
you can imagine you've got task a then
two tasks B and C and and then D depends
on B and C so it'll form sort of like a
diamond shape on to the actual the
business logic of the tasks you remember
at the beginning it was referencing a
template echo echo is defined in the
same llamó file and you can see that
echo echo is running alpine Linux
container it can be your own container
it can be a Python container and it's
simply running get rid of this
it's simply running the echo command
from bash in your shell basically but
this could be a Python program doing
model training or data preparation or
hyper parameter tuning anything really
and you can see that it's taking as a
parameter input message that we were
defining above so task a was sending a
task B was sending B tasks he was
sending C now you're going to submit the
dag to augur to running on your
kubernetes cluster so there you go you
can watch it so this is one mechanism of
interacting with the dag at runtime you
can visualize it running in your machine
so you can see that task a ran first at
the top here and B and C are pending
that you can see B and C running in
parallel and BNC you're finished and
finally D so there's a great little
augur CLI tool that lets you interact
with the the DAGs and you can dive in
with the CLI and look at the logs on
each container you can it's just a
wrapper around
cube cuddle so you can also use the cube
CTL as well to interact the the agro
tool itself just has a few nice touches
around it that I'll go specific but you
could use your existing kubernetes tool
chain if you if you needed to
so now I'm going to that there's a list
you can see what can happen I'm now
going to submit the same the same dag to
the cluster but this time I'm not gonna
watch it I'm going to open it up in the
web UI so I've submitted the dag and
here you can see the dag running and
updating in real time there's the sort
of diamond shape that I was talking
about and that's the completed dag you
can sort of click on the different tasks
and you can see the parameters that were
passed to it and you can also see the
log output so there the message value
was a as we defined in the llamo same
thing for B
and D is showing the message about USD
now that's a simple single log message
it could be the it could be heaps and
heaps of logs from your Python program
or your spark application or whatever
you can also inspect the Yama so there's
the actual yama of the workflow in the
tool okay so that was the first demo
depending on how much time we have it's
the time for one more it's time for one
more so now I'll show you another demo
it'll go through similar steps this time
it's coin flip this dag is doing a bit
more of the conditional logic and you
can see how it can branch so again at
the top it's a custom resource
definition of kind workflow it's called
tag diamond coin flip our entry point is
diamond this time and you've got similar
tasks a b c d that are all using the
coin flip template
now if we dive into the the coin flip
you can see that it actually itself is
made up of steps so each each node each
task in the in the in the Argo dere can
actually reference another workflow so
you can have workflows with in workflows
so this coin flip one is having
conditional steps run so when the coin
flip output is heads it will run the
heads template and if the coin flip
output is tails it will recursively run
coin flip so this sort of gives you
conditional termination of your dag and
you'll see that they reference the flip
coin container and flip coin container
is running Python and this doesn't you
don't need to put your code in your Yama
file this is purely for demonstration
purposes it's got a convenient here doc
style approach where you can inline your
code but you could equally build your
own docker containers and publish them
to docker hub or you'll contain a
registry of choice and in reference them
there as we have referenced the Python
Alpine 3.6 so that little snippet of
code as you can probably imagine is
randomly going to return heads or tails
and the head container so remember there
were two containers in play here there
were the flip coin container and the
hits container which would terminate the
computation this one is just a simple
echo it was heads it's going to run it's
just running on Alpine and it'll yeah
when there it will return heads so this
will become a lot easier to see when
it's which they actually run
so when tails it'll run coin flip else
it will run echo here it's no it was
heads rather
to speed this along a bit
all right finally okay so we're gonna
submit the dag and watch it on the
command line so there we go
task a is executing flip a coin it
didn't evaluate heads it evaluate tails
so it's evaluating flip coin again we
finally hit a heads now B and C are
doing the same thing they're flipping
coins waiting for heads looks like C hit
heads B is still going trying to find
heads it goes finds heads and finally
the D the bottom of the diamond DS
evaluating now didn't find heads it
looks like it found hits and finished so
that's a bit tricky to understand what's
going on from the command line so
submitted it again to the cluster and
the storm will follow it in the UI so
it's followed in the UI so there you go
flipping coins flipping coins looks like
a is completed being Co running now
being see you're running flip coin you
can sort of see it's dynamically
building the deck
I think my Oh finally DS runnin DS
flipping coins and it looks like it hit
hits so that sort of gives you a little
bit of a taste of what you can do in
Argo you can see the logs for heads and
I'm about to run out of time so if
there's any questions I can probably
take a few now otherwise I'll see you in
the office hours
[Applause]